attention si vous étiez un défaut marina
vous seriez quoi la radinerie way et toi
les marinas pour me venger des cuvées
dit que vous étiez une injure dit va te
faire cuire le q si vous étiez une
maladie enregistrés un toc troubles
obsessionnels c'est le seul travail
salon j'écris la thur une pièce qui sera
produite à bientôt
les prochaines est alors devenue la
meilleure vannes pour voir ça commence
c'est demain qu'il y ait programme fixé
allez tous vous faire reculer
ouais c'est bien je tâtonne belvilla
syndrome gilles de la tourette donc
c'est normal qu'ils disent
si vous étiez une maladie ou un petit
rhume mais avec plein de morgue
voilà c'est exactement ce calaisien
si vous étiez un accident alors moi je
serais un accident très idiot qui est
arrivé pour de vrai à la mère d'un ami
elle s'est auto écrasé avec sa voiture
c'est à dire qu'elle était dans un
parking de son parking lac était en
pente et elle a oublié le frein à main
est sorti pour prendre un truc paf le
pied s'est coincé et attendait c'était
très grave parce qu'on a dû lui ôter les
deux poules to know
j'aimerais dire mairie 20 si vous étiez
une perversion marina est vieillot fini
si vous étiez une perversion je serais
ce que vous m'avez proposé de faire en
coulisses tout à tuer détient 10 une
boulons
jean trahison aller chez fogiel il
trahison des jeux ballan triste que vous
m'avez proposé de faire un colis je lui
tiens un poison à la cigarette
j'aime trop c'est bien bien là bravo
bravo la nicotine bravo moi j'y serai un
poisson rouge si vous êtes une femme
beaucoup aux lola aucune non mais ça va
on a droit d'être très grossier il
attend dé moi je demande tout le temps
oh là là je serai une panne
d'électricité pendant la finale de la
coupe du monde voilà tu la rendit alors
moi aussi parce que presque j'ai rajouté
l'aveyron macquarie tu l'a plus fait un
moment à l'interné depuis trois ans
si vous étiez une infirmité et les
haricots
je tiens à face à quelqu'un qui fera un
crime parfait
d'ailleurs je sais ce que c'est que le
coup parfait j'y réfléchisse à un crime
gratuit
parce que si c'est un acte gratuit c'est
impossible on se retrouve alors ce sera
marine a donné des bons conseils fumée
crime gratuit parfait si vous étiez une
mort pas définitive si vous étiez un
microbe un microbe de ahmed 80
car au mercy serge même si je trouve que
je suis mal habillé merci quoi il a dit
que c'était ma mawi d'habitude et puis
le public ne sait pas que serge khalfon
s'habiller exclusivement en prada donc
forcément ce que tu vois un t-shirt
utilisateurs le mieux habillé de paris
sans réalisateur mannequin on l'appelle
réalisateur mais quatre seulement 12
d'entre nous dis-moi serge tout le monde
le sait un chat en panne et par
d'échangés